hey this is pressure Walker here's an
interesting integral I saw what is the
integral from 0 to Pi
of cosine squared of cosine X Plus sine
squared of sine X DX
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
to solve this problem label the entire
integral as being equal to I now let's
look at the graphs from 0 to Pi
you'll notice that each graph is
symmetrical about the line X is equal to
pi over 2 right in the center in other
words if we take these graphs and find
their mirror images about this line we
will get exactly the same graphs
so we can take advantage of this to
evaluate the integral
the integral of this function from 0 to
Pi will exactly be the same thing as
twice the integral of this function
going from 0 to pi over 2 which is
halfway
so now let's do a change of coordinates
let's say that X is equal to pi over 2
minus y this means DX is equal to
negative d y
we also need to change the limits of
integration when X is equal to zero Y is
equal to pi over 2 and when X is equal
to pi over 2 Y is equal to zero so we
get that I is equal to two times the
integral from pi over two to zero
then we substitute in X is equal to pi
over 2 minus y
and finally DX becomes negative d y
so now let's simplify this
cosine of pi over 2 minus y is equal to
sine of Y and sine of pi over 2 minus y
is equal to cosine of Y
then we have this negative d y which we
can cancel out by flipping the limits of
integration
so the integral becomes two times the
integral from 0 to pi over 2 of cosine
squared of sine y plus sine squared of
cosine y d y
we now have two integrals we'll just do
one more change of coordinates we'll
make all of these y's into X's
so we can now add these two integrals
together and we get that 2i is equal to
2 times the integral from 0 to pi over 2
of cosine squared of cosine X Plus sine
squared of cosine X plus cosine squared
of sine X Plus sine squared of sine X
all DX
we can now make a simplification cosine
squared of something plus sine squared
of the same argument will be equal to
one then we have cosine squared of
something plus sine squared of the same
something so this will also be equal to
one
so two times this integral is equal to
two times the integral from 0 to pi over
two of two DX
we now just evaluate this integral and
this is all equal to 2 pi we then divide
by 2 and we get that I is equal to Pi
and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problem one video at a
time
foreign